So who can really move to Spain?
If you've been following me for a while,
you'll know that I speak specifically about living in Spain
and various aspects of moving here from,
for example, the United Kingdom.
But some of you have asked me, John,
who's got it the easiest, who's got it the most challenging
when it comes down to actually being able to stay here
for longer than 90 days? So
the first people that we're gonna discuss right now
are people that are retired.
These guys are gonna go on the non lucrative visa.
What makes it easy for them is No. 1.
They do not need to work. Now,
that means that they need to have a certain amount of income
from their pension or savings.
But they're not taking jobs away from the marketplace.
And they come here, they're self sufficient.
They just need to prove their financial standing
for immigration purposes.
The next on the list is gonna be people that are working on
what's known as a digital nomad visa.
These people have got permission to live here
because they've got jobs already.
They're not taking jobs from the marketplace.
You notice there's a reoccurring theme here.
They've got the salary to support themselves.
The next on the list at No. 3
is gonna be people that are entrepreneurs.
The self employed visa, that's gonna be the next one.
There are other types of visas.
There's family reunification visas,
student visas.
But we're not Gonna touch on them because they're few and far between.
The last. Who's gonna find it most difficult to live in Spain?
People with no job, no skills and no money.
It's just not gonna happen unless you've got legal rights to live here,
IE you're a Spanish citizen.
With that being said, if you wanna move to Spain,
message me, because I've got it done.
I'm helping people that want to get it done
and we're having a great time over here doing it.
Consultations are available.
I'll see you in the comments.